MIRANDA DEVINE, THANKS MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE HAVE JUST HEARD FROM THE CEO
OF TWITTER, JACK DORSEY WHO
TWEETED "OUR COMMUNICATION
AROUND OUR ACTIONS WITH
"THE NEW YORK POST" ARTICLE WAS
NOT GREAT.
BLOCKING URLs WITH ZERO
CONTEXT WHY WE ARE BLOCKING, AND
ACCEPTABLE."
HUH.
WRITES LIKE A CHILD.
MANAGES THE COMPANY LIKE ONE
TOO.
BY THE WAY THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
WAS ABLE TO CALL THE
STORY "DISCREDITED, BECAUSE BIG
TECH IS TRYING TO DISCREDIT IT.
NO REPORTER HAS TAKEN A LOOK AT
THE STORY AND CONCLUDED SURE,
THIS IS A RUSSIAN FABRICATION.
PUTIN DID THIS.
THAT’S RIDICULOUS.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN IS USING BIG
TECH AS A PRETEXT FOR NOT
RESPONDING.
BIG TECH COURSES TRYING TO
PREVENT YOU FROM READING IT AT
ALL.
WHERE DOES THIS GO FROM HERE?
IF BIDEN IS ELECTED, DO YOU
THINK, DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT
THE BIG TECH COMPANIES ARE GOING
TO STOP DOING THE BIDDING OF
THEIR MASTERS IN WASHINGTON?
NOT A CHANCE.
YOU THINK BIG TECH IS WHEN YOU
SUDDENLY THINK, YOU’RE ALLOWED
TO THINK FOR YOURSELF?
NO.
LAST NIGHT WE QUESTION WHETHER
MASKS WERE EFFECTIVE AT THE
TRANSMISSION OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
AS WE DO THAT WE CITED DATA
DIRECTLY FROM THE CDC.
WE PULLED OFF THEIR WEBSITE AS
WELL AS OTHER SCIENTIFIC
SOURCES.
"SCIENCE" MAGAZINE FOR EXAMPLE.
ONE STUDY FOUND THAT MORE THAN
70% OF PATIENCE WHO CONTRACTED
THE CORONAVIRUS SAID THEY HAD
ALWAYS WON A MASK.
ANOTHER 14% SAID THEY USUALLY
DID.
WE TOLD YOU THAT LAST NIGHT WE
POSTED THE SEGMENT ON FACEBOOK.
TODAY WE LEARNED THAT FACEBOOK
IS CALLING OUR REPORTING "PARTLY
FALSE."
WE QUOTED THE CDC!
THEY RESTRICTED THE DISTRIBUTION
OF THE POST TO PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM SEEING IT.
WE CAN’T SAY THIS ENOUGH.
THE DATA THAT WE PUT ON
TELEVISION LAST NIGHT WERE FROM
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL.
WE USE THEIR NUMBERS.